you know how irritating it is to choose  the right type face for a project or how  maddening it is to perfectly pair to  fonts how about the fact that you can't  seem to get kerning right I've been  through the same struggles in my career  and that's why I created typography  technique hi there my name is Cameron  and I've created a power-packed mini  course on everything typography that can  be fully watched and understood in about  20 minutes once you've completed my mini  course you will know how to pick and  pair typefaces how to Kern the right way  have an understanding of current  typography trend plus you will know and  understand the essential rules of  typography best of all my visual  approach makes learning this stuff  interesting check out the course and  quickly discover how to create beautiful  typography in any project